there was this hilarious video this
summer about him and yic in Serbia in
the summer and they was like some horse
race is this dude really like obsessed
with horses yeah man Joker all offseason
is in Serbia drinking beer and watching
horses he definitely likes horses more
than basketball man we'll be in there
getting ready for practice at training
camp and he's on his phone watching the
horse races he probably didn't touch a
basketball all off season and somehow he
got better and then that's who AG is as
a person he'll travel in offseason by
himself so I know he pulled up on Joker
and I know they had a good time out
there and ser I think I'm going try to
get out there next year see what yoke
has going just see the culture out there
he tells me like it's fun out there he
says the night life is way better than
it is over here so I'm going go turn up
with
Joker do
[Music]
that